santiago your test result from the
sergeant's exam has arrived ooh
everybody make room amy needs adequate
space to do her signature dork dance i
don't know if there's gonna be a dork
dance oh look how small that envelope is
that's not a big good news envelope
that's a little bad news envelope what
that's nuts sarge tell her envelope size
doesn't matter if i'm being honest i got
a much bigger envelope oh god unhelpful
terry very unhelpful mine was bigger too
okay i just won't ever open it that way
i'll never get rejected fine i'll open
it no no no
do it harder you're not leaving this
room what the hell is going on i can't
let you quit yes but why the candles and
rose petals
is that mr mclean i hear cause someone's
about to die oh my god why is captain
hold here cause he's gonna wait
are you dressed like bonnie bedelia and
die hard i am for sexy reasons yes oh
boy jake why is he here because he's
quitting the force so i brought him here
to convince him not to but obviously
that is not important anymore all right
captain it's been a good run thank you
for teaching me the importance of a tie
in the workplace and the door's right
over here
hey detective jake peralta dr rossi i'm
the new medical examiner don't let me
get in your way i'm sure you have a lot
to do actually i've been given a direct
order to do nothing so
what brings you here
okay
all right
sorry sorry now everyone be sure to put
those on because it's impossible to
solve crimes unless you're wearing a tie
light off the captain that man is gonna
be my rabbi okay first of all when you
use the word rabbi you know that turns
me on and that's unfair in the work
environment so i marked all the corners
where taxi has been spotted on this map
you'll probably notice right away that
it makes the shape of a boob this looks
great confirms steven's story he says
his dealer hangs out here
in the underboob he said he'll point him
out to us so you approach on foot from
the south and me and devin will be in an
unmarked car here whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
me and devin didn't you mean
devin and i oh god i corrected your
grammar
are you so proud of me are you horrified
are you super horny oh
amy when'd you get here
you've come for my conjugal capabilities
you're looking
real good girl
oop lost a booby and no matter
i'll just build another one
more mashed potatoes
i told you i'll always be one step ahead
of you you can't surprise me you're
boring you know what spices up a
relationship co-owning a multi-tiered
marketing ignore him look there are
three tramps the only way we're gonna
win is if we team up good point
i guess my response is
rotten hell crap-face also i love you
and i treasure you and you bore me gosh
you're being so mean
do it more i hope you die
bye
i didn't want to do this but i do know
one way we could get the money you'd
make a decent prostitute i'd make an
amazing prostitute our boss is headed
this way everyone has to clear the
hallway right now
wow she is great at shushing i know
she's like a librarian me like a sexy
librarian no
a regular one oh
what do we have here a 34 year old
caucasian male who is dead very dead
cause of death initial assessment blunt
force trauma but what do i find when i
probe a little farther bruising around
the neck and
ocean water in the lungs ooh how long
have you been dead body four days gross
bloating odors uh uh 24 hours perfect
here we go you're two minutes late i
called all the emergency rooms i know i
went home from your place to shower and
i'm so tired that i fell asleep while
shaving my legs but we went to bed so
early property brothers was over a tenth
i mean
sex we do it she's tired from all the
doing it who are you talking to precinct
come on man yeah gina big news terry's
friend got back to us and he says
they're doing security for bayside
high's number one wrestler ac slater
that's right mario lopez oh my god i had
such a big crush on him yeah we all had
a big crush on ac slater get in line
[Laughter]
i'll be cooler when we meet him i should
hope so okay it's time to celebrate you
know what that means this bee needs a c
in her a oh my god this babe needs a
coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music oh
my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of
coconuts i'm going to stomp on your
dreams it's fun to see you so passionate
i will slit you both open from mouth to
anus and wear you like jackets huh is it
weird that that turned me on a little
bit
and three 6203.66 thousand two hundred
and four
i am so glad i lost this bet i never
find time for things i enjoy this is so
unsatisfying you're not even sweating
it's too easy get on my back jake no i'm
not get it on my back jay coming strong
man
diane hello this is my friend gina and
this is detective peralta they work with
my raymond oh peralta you are so old to
behave the way you do oh
what i'm sure he vents about everyone on
the squad nope just you damn it diane
what are you doing after this so gerald
did anything happen to raymond last week
did he seem like something or someone
had him in a bad mood it was his day to
pick the music and he chose haydn so he
was in a good mood or a bad mood a great
mood jake oh you're jake damn it what
are you doing after this gerald
so how'd you convince the whole squad to
betray me what'd you offer them i asked
them if they wanted to embarrass you and
they instantly said yes
i'm not gonna lie that turns me on a
little bit
stop clapping you idiots we gotta move
no
i love her charles get it together i
want you and jake to go to gowanus power
sub station that's where the transformer
exploded work with esu get us a
timetable for the power being restored
and hurry wow look at my pregnant wife
taking charge i don't know whether to be
proud or turned on i said hurry oh my
god it's both
happy oh yeah
you look like every girl at every bot
mitzvah i ever had a crush on
let's see the bow
just like jenny gildenhorn why do i wish
you had braces should we get you braces
no that's too much oh and amy
your dress makes you look like a mermaid
okay i'll see in a little bit
oh detective santiago big date tonight
how do i look well i think you look
sorry that was supposed to be a cat call
i don't know how this works what
happened i thought you guys were
supposed to be at the warehouse party we
got egged some of the shell got in my
contacts and my hair and my mouth and my
bra i can't tell if that's hot or not
not hot eggshell on my bra is not hot
well it's kind of hot
boobs go on a bra
up top
whew my man
fantastic 3 000 identical blue doors
looks like we all got door duty
oh yeah
before
good one
you look great
so
did they diffuse the bomb yeah one of
them oh you didn't hear there was a
second bomb
you butt
your butt is to bomb oh on our
anniversary
pregnant nice
means you had sex damn right i did and i
forgot my birth control yeah yeah hey
can you sign this arrest report for
augustine in the buyer sure
man i forgot how long your signature
takes just gonna watch braveheart on my
phone real quick
uh given the circumstances i could see
how that might have seemed like
flirty teasing or something but
i was legit being critical you have a
problem
now even that sounded like banter now
all right there's only one way out of
this for me it's got to get super cruel
prepare to have your physical flaws
pointed out amy talking about your tall
butt and your weird elbows
jake it's okay oh thank you
this whole night was really weird i know
i just
uh i want everything to go back how it
was you know it's so awkward yeah you're
right we shouldn't date cops it's we're
a great team we work great together
i don't want to mess that up yeah i
don't want everything to change yeah me
neither okay then that's that
detective peralta detective santiago
see you
around the precinct yep
talbot
you